[Musique]
bonsoir est heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 7,8 le journal voici les
titres vendredi soir luc chatel a fait
escale à versailles pour soutenir le
candidat de son camp à l'élection
présidentielle françois fillon
une réunion publique était organisée à
l'université interâges les robots
étaient à l'honneur ce week end à
montigny le bretonneux l'association
planète sciences organisé l'édition 2010
est des trophées de robotique une
trentaine d' équipes d'île de france en
compétition
nous étions sur place et puis on parlera
aussi de sport avec l'école d'ingénieurs
centrale supélec qui vient d'organiser
ce week end la première édition révisée
de son raid sportif night and day 400
participants étaient inscrits on débute
ce journal avec deux disparitions
inquiétantes autour de rambouillet mona
et martin tous deux âgés d'une vingtaine
d'années ont fait font l'objet
d'intenses recherches et sont signalées
disparues depuis plusieurs jours pour le
moment la police affirme qu'il n'y a
aucun lien avéré entre les deux
disparitions empêtré dans la sphère du
pénélope gate le candidat à l'élection
présidentielle françois fillon peut
compter sur des ténors de son parti les
républicains pour le soutenir par me luc
chatel l'ex-ministre a fait escale à
versailles vendredi soir pour soutenir
son champion
un reportage de camille lambert
opération rassemblement ce vendredi à
versailles luc chatel était l'invité
d'honneur d'une réunion publique
organisée en soutien à françois fillon
il est venu défendre le programme du
candidat à la présidentielle je vais
parler du fond
nos électeurs veulent qu'on parle du
fond nos électeurs veulent qu'on leur
montre les solutions pour sortir de la
situation dans laquelle nous sommes
aujourd'hui voilà les socialistes on a
fait c'est le pays économiquement donc
notre devoir c'est de venir ici défendre
notre candidat défendre nos idées pour
réformer en profondeur ce pays malgré
les soupçons d'emplois fictifs qui
pèsent sur sa femme et ses enfants
les sympathisants républicains restent
mobilisés selon une enquête ifop publiée
ce week end
70% d'entre eux veulent que françois
fillon maintienne sa candidature
on peut dire l'objectif est atteint
puisque on avait 450 personnes ce soir
on avait la plupart des parlementaires
soient des sénateurs le député qui était
là le président du sénat gérard larcher
le président du conseil départemental
permet d'y et donc oui c'est
indispensable de tous nous réunir dans
cette période on va dire un peu de
turbulences un fillon a fait largement
ses preuves
1 c'est un homme qui est montée
progressivement qui a pris qui a fini
premier ministre ont un moment qui a
résolu une crise mondiale avec sarkozy
mais je vais vous dire que on a
confiance et qu'on se moque de cette
petite histoire ridicule qui a été mais
surmédiatisé préparer machiavéliquement
mais reste à convaincre l'ensemble des
électeurs selon le même sondage ifop 65%
des français souhaitent que françois
fillon se retire il ya la course à la
présidentielle mais aussi les
législatives et les déclarations se
poursuivre dans les yvelines
samedi dernier le front de gauche a
investi il lut miserait dans la 11e
circonscription des yvelines
une campagne qu'il souhaite au plus près
de la population
un reportage de nicolas landry le pont
de la marsa 20 attrape avec la gare de
triage en toile de fond c'est le lieu
choisi par luc miserait pour déclarer sa
candidature aux élections législatives
dans la 11e circonscription des yvelines
une campagne lancée sur la thématique
des transports par exemple de la gare de
triage de trappes
qui est aujourd'hui en jachère alors que
là ce sont à la fois des centaines
d'emplois à la fois on a d'un côté
l'aspect marchandises qui est important
et puis de l'autre côté on à la gare de
trappes
mais il ya aussi le prolongement de
l'autoroute a12 que nous on n'a pas
enterré ainsi monsieur font mouche à
enterrer ben nous on l'a pas enterrer
ces problèmes là il faut s'y atteler à
la fois pour les problèmes
d'environnement et de santé publique
mais en même temps pour fluidifier la
circulation et l'irrigation de ces zones
industrielles et commerciales conseiller
municipal d'opposition à la mairie de
trappes luc mise rémission une campagne
de terrain en allant à la rencontre des
citoyens déjà ça fait longtemps qu'ils
travaillent sur le secteur sur trappe
l'oci dans le mouvement associatif et
c'est important d'avoir géré un candidat
j'irai qui est bien ancrée dans le
terrain connaît bien son secteur c'est
une candidature qui est portée largement
à gauche pour construire un
rassemblement le plus large possible des
forces qui se réclament
je dirais delà de la bataille contre les
forces de l'argent
prochain rendez vous sur des lieux
symboliques de la 11e circonscription
notamment au prisme à elancourt pour
évoquer les politiques culturelles à
elle encore une quinzaine de jeunes ont
lancé samedi soir des bouteilles de
verre et des pierres contre le poste de
police municipale
une attaque qui n'a pas causé de dégâts
majeurs sur le bâtiment et qui semble
faire écho à la ferté au ce jeune
victime d'un viol présumée lors de son
interpellation par des policiers il ya
de cela trois semaines
écoutez à ce propos le maire d'elancourt
jean michel fourgous s'était pas d'une
extrême violence son plein en cours mais
bon c'est quand même quand même très
il faut prendre des mesures quand même
vite ces jeunes qui pensent que en a le
droit de s'exprimer comme ça c'est
l'argent de leurs parents qui payent les
services publics dont la police
municipale c'est les impôts de leurs
parents rien donc sauf qu'il faut le
faire respecter
donc c'est pour ça qu'il ya bien sûr une
enquête en cours
pour les amateurs de robots ce week end
a eu lieu l'édition 2010 est des
trophées de robotique organisé par
l'association planète sciences
une trentaine d' équipe de l'île de
france se sont affrontées à l'occasion
de l'événement les jeunes de montigny
ont reçu le prix du développement
durable un reportage d'anne laure
languir ses romans créé par des jeunes
âgés de 7 à 18 ans ont une mission de la
plus haute importance
ériger un village sur la lune à cette
fin chaque équipe à 90 secondes pour
rassembler des matériaux de construction
celle qui rapporte le plus d'éléments
gagne la partie
au début c'était difficile car on
n'avait pas beaucoup d'entraînements la
cre qu'on va jamais on va jamais s'en
sortir on a réussi à se qualifier les
parties en quarts de finale
malheureusement pour les jeunes
trappistes l' aventure s'arrête là en
revanche l'équipe de montigny le
bretonneux remporte le prix du
développement durable c'est une fierté
c'est une première année et donc on n'a
pas fait très loin dans le podium et on
est content d'avoir eu un prix si tous
les participants n'ont pas empoché de
prix ils savent désormais construire un
robot à travers cette compétition
l'association planète sciences veut
sensibiliser les jeunes aux matières
scientifiques avec un objectif c'est de
rendre un peu la science la science
joyeuse on prend du temps on passe du
temps en équipe pour réaliser un projet
et puis à la fin du projet on vient se
confronter à d'autres équipes dans un
joyeux
voilà une joyeuse confrontation un
joyeux match qui se termine voilà par
beaucoup de vainqueurs et beaucoup de
plaisir dans les dans les ateliers des
équipes dans sa mission l'association
est épaulé par des partenaires officiels
comme le centre national d'études
spatiales le cnes dont on pouvait voir
le logo sur certaines
num c'est une équipe de
savigny-le-temple en seine et marne et
qui a atteint le haut du podium
elle participera donc en avril prochain
à la finale nationale
quant aux autres pas de regrets ils se
préparent déjà à revenir l'an prochain
il y a les robots mais les humains aussi
continue de faire du sport
l'école d'ingénieurs centrale supélec
organisé ce week-end la première édition
de revisser de son raid sportif night
and day 400 participants ont
courageusement parcouru 12 km à pied
dans la nuit de vendredi à samedi
un reportage de nicolas kirilow vite et
de nicolas gendry du volley assis du tir
à l'arc ou encore un stand de formule 1
le jour un trailer la nuit avec pour
unique éclairage une lampe frontale la
nouvelle édition du raid organisé par
les étudiants de centrale supélec se
voulait varie en offre sportive pour sa
nouvelle formule objectif attirer un
maximum de participants
le but ça a été de faire un événement
qui sont accessibles à tous aussi bien
pour le niveau sportif que pour que pour
l'ambiance
donc c'est à dire cette fois c'est pour
ça que le nouveau le nouveau format a
été adopté avec des activités dont qui
sont quand même à caractère sportif mais
aussi le village de rambouillet et c'est
une course
plusieurs tracés en vallée de chevreuse
ont permis notamment aux plus courageux
de parcourir jusqu'à 110 km en deux
jours en équipe de quatre et dans une
ambiance décontractée une condition
essentielle quand le corps est ainsi
mise à rude épreuve
nous on est on est un peu des sportifs
du dimanche à on est pas on n'a pas
l'habitude de courir
mais on s'en sort et on aura quelques
crampes pendant un ou deux mois mais on
va survivre
le tir à l'arc
alors je sais pas trop comment on s'est
débrouillé
je connais chasseurs de sangliers qui a
touché deux cibles ici une chasseuse
donc c'est assez osé pour ce week-end
sportif des entreprises des étudiants
étrangers et des personnes à mobilité
réduite étaient également conviés à
relever le défi
prochaine étape pour les meilleurs
d'entre eux en avril avec cette fois ci
une course organisée en occitanie et 250
km au programme
félicitations à eux ils sont très
courageux
on termine ce journal avec la 75e
édition du paris-nice la compétition
cycliste passera par des yvelines les 5
et 6 mars pour la première étape entre
bois d'arcy et la vallée de chevreuse
pour animer le village départ la société
100% forme proposera gratuitement au
public de s'essayer à du fitness biking
mais participeront les participants
verront en direct leur fréquence
cardiaque pendant un effort on écoute le
responsable jean michel bédel au micro
de michael et demi d'euros c'est
accessible à tous puisque chaque
participant est équipé d'un
cardiofréquencemètre qui nous permet en
direct et en visuel d'avoir la fréquence
cardiaque est affichée sur un écran de
télévision et que et donc chacun va
pouvoir exprimer fonction de sa forme
physique
une difficulté et donc l'affichage va
permettre au coach de gérer l'effort de
chacun donc c'est ouvert à tous c'est la
fin de ce 7 8 le journal merci de nous
avoir suivis prochaine édition
demain à 18 heures bonne soirée à tous
[Musique]